la couture propose mais la rue dispose
cependant je serais bien étonné quand le
soleil sera revenu qu'on ne voit pas
partout des robes tout l'oil tout petit
c'est tout rayé pour les hommes aussi
veste 120 heures le 2 en 1 cela
ressemble à un tailleur mais quand on
abandonne rester jupe on a une robe
froncée
si on ne choisit pas le flou c'est la
robe droite et fendue en forme de
tablier noué à la taille ou boutonnet
avec des ouvertures coquine peu dans
tous les sens et des surpiqûres
le fonds de revenu des parents par est
lui aussi fendue sur le côté
on le trouve en tunique de plage
comme en imperméable
et les robes sur total on compte encore
défense
elles viennent d'arabie ou du vietnam
avec coiffure a sorti
hommes et femmes je romps à shérazade et
aladdin avec des pantalons bouffants et
des turbans de qualif pour la ville ou
la plage
ban
pendant
on serait même facilement berbère de la
tête au sac nouée à la taille fedayin de
charme et toutes ces orientale d'une
saison porteront robe du soir en forme
de djellabas tout cela aura un doux
parfum de pétrole et deux mille et une
nuits
vous préférez l'occident alors c'est
chicago 1939 avait costume rayé tennis
féminin masculin et retour en force du
pantalon avec casquette et visière
la combinaison de garagiste tous sexes
est toute propre
plus de bas est basé le pantalon sera
large et raccourcis où l'on est serré il
remontera carrément genou en bermuda de
ville
même ceux qui prétendent échapper à la
mode ont du mal à trouver autre chose
que les teams cigarettes très étroit
enfin pour oublier que les prix du prêt
à porter vont de 600 à 2000 francs
voici comment se déshabillera rêvons
quelques secondes les femmes pensent
qu'au soleil les hommes à cette sirène